the fifth circuit court of appeals puts
a hold on joe biden's vaccine mandate a
handful of congressional republicans
hand democrats a win on infrastructure
and california rewrites how math should
be taught i'm ben shapiro this is the
bench bureau show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first here is your reminder
black friday isn't when you should start
saving money you should start saving
money right now by switching over to
puretalk usa because here's the thing
you're paying way too much for your cell
phone bill you could be cutting that
thing in half if you switch over to pure
talk pure talk gives you killer 5g
coverage on one of the largest 5g
networks in the country and still saves
the average family over 800 a year i
made the switch the coverage is
excellent their us-based customer
service actually cares about you and
pure tax prices are pretty much
wholesale you've got unlimited talk
texts and six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month you can keep your number
keep your phone or this money and get
black friday prices on new phones like
the iphone 12 for just 479 bucks which
is a major savings they've got a 30-day
risk-free guarantee you really have
nothing to lose now you might think you
need one of the big providers you don't
they use one of the same cell phone
coverage situations as the big cell
phone coverage providers so why not
switch over to pure talk at the same
exact coverage as one of the big guys
for half the price go to puretalk.com
shop for the plan and phone that's right
for you enter promo code shapiro you'll
save 50 off your first month and save on
a new phone that's puretalk.com promo
code shapiro pure talk is simply smarter
wireless some restrictions apply see
site for details alrighty so joe biden
is flailing the man has a lot of trouble
bill back better is basically dead on
arrival he just got shellacked in
virginia he nearly lost the governorship
of new jersey for his party he just came
back from cop26 this giant global
warming conference with nothing like
with really nothing and people mocking
him openly at this point the biggest
story so far to emerge from cop26
involving joe biden comes courtesy of
the uk daily mail quote he is supposed
to be committed to reducing emissions
when president joe biden produced a
little natural gas of his own at the
cop26 summit it was audible enough to
make the duchess of cornwall blush an
informed source has told the mail on
sunday that camilla was taken aback to
hear biden break wind as they made
polite small talk at the global climate
change gathering in glasgow last week
which is always great fresh on the heels
of rumors that he had literally crapped
his pants in the vatican it was long and
loud and impossible to ignore the source
camilla hasn't stopped talking about it
the president met the duchess during a
reception on monday at the kelvin grove
art gallery attended by prince charles
the duke and duchess of cambridge and
boris johnson just hours earlier the 78
year old nickname sleepy joe by donald
trump had appeared to doze off during
the opening addresses prompting more
questions from his political rivals over
his fitness for office this is not the
first time that biden has faced claims
that he broke win publicly in may 2020
republicans including donald trump jr
posted a video clip of biden containing
a suspicious noise while live streaming
in exchange with pennsylvania governor
tom wolf however a separate video which
circulated last month and briefly turned
it on twitter under fargate was found to
have been doctored to include fake
flatulence
so
yeah it's always great when
the big headline coming out of a global
warming reduction conference is that you
have emitted
carbon from your ass that's always
that's always a great look and again
that is just i think writ small what
this biden administration is right now
the american people are unhappy with the
bite administration they've done nothing
of note on the foreign policy stage
other than to make a bunch of weird
noises over at this cop26 conference and
then also surrender afghanistan oh yeah
i forgot also the uss navy is now the us
navy is now commissioning the uss harvey
milk because we need a navy ship we need
to name a navy ship after a gay rights
activist who also in his life
was pretty credibly having sex with
underage guys
definitely need a navy ship named after
that that's great meanwhile the chinese
are developing like a thousand nuclear
weapons so things are going great for
the biden administration and and here's
the thing
it doesn't seem like things are set to
get better any time soon for joe biden
in fact last week you saw that joe biden
snapped at peter ducey from fox news
when ducey
read a wall street journal report and
pointed out that the biden
administration was reportedly going to
give 450 000
to people who had crossed the border
illegally and been separated from their
families and biden just yelled at peter
ducey and then it turns out that he was
wrong and his own administration had to
walk it back well then over the weekend
he snapped again at a fox news reporter
this time snapping by saying why
wouldn't you want me to pay them so
remember just a few hours earlier he was
like how why would you say that no one's
getting paid and no one's getting paid
and now he's like why would you be angry
if we're paying people what's wrong with
that
here we go
you said last week uh that this report
about migrant families at the border
getting payments uh with garbage no i
didn't say that let's get straight you
said everybody coming across the border
gets 500 450 thousand dollars
referring to okay now here's the thing
if in fact because of the the outrageous
behavior of the last administration
you coming across the border whether it
was legal or illegal and you lost your
child
you lost your child it's gone
you deserve some kind of compensation no
matter what circumstance so now he's
just as angry about people correctly
reporting it as he was when he thought
that they were misreporting it he's very
angry if you watch a trial
okay this isn't going well for joe biden
he's completely inauthentic nobody takes
him seriously he's literally farting on
the world stage he's leaving stinkers on
the world stage even the media have now
turned on him to a certain extent abc's
good morning america did a report on the
supply chain impact on normal families
across the country it didn't look great
for joe biden
this year like charlie brown's
thanksgiving you may have to trim your
list of trimmings what kind of a
thanksgiving dinner is this
where's the turkey chuck
top turkey cellar butterball says it
doesn't expect an overall gobbler
shortage but if you're hunting for a
smaller bird they could be tough to find
and it's not just the main dish at risk
of running a foul for your cranberry
sides ocean spray tells abc it's
committed to meeting customer demand but
experienced a variety of supply chain
challenges okay and so joe biden's
response to this is to get super angry
at everybody for pointing out the supply
chain challenges which again have been
exacerbated by bad union contracts at
the ports which have been facilitated by
democrats for decades as well as the
giant labor shortage that continues to
hamper the economic recovery by the way
there's some very good statistical
evidence to demonstrate that the labor
uptick that we saw last month was almost
completely due to the fact that all of
those benefits the federal government
was providing people to stay home
started to run out and so people started
to go back to work the charts are very
telling on that particular subject so in
a second we'll get to joe biden's
response to the supply chain crisis and
it's always just indignation just
indignation of being questioned this is
the thing about joe biden he's always
been this
i know that we were supposed to pretend
that he was super empathetic and
wonderful he was the kind of guy who's
going to sniff your hair and rub your
shoulders and make you feel better about
yourself or alternatively just sniff
your hair and rub your shoulders and
make you feel creepy but
joe biden has always been the jerk who
yells at you if you if you cross him
and he's always been the guy who if you
cross him he says
well fat look fat he's always been that
guy i'll get some more of this from joe
biden in just one second first let's
talk about a podcast that you might want
to give a listen to i'm talking of
course about the jordan harbinger show
it's a podcast you really should give a
try i know every day somebody tells you
you have to listen to some podcast or
other you mostly just blow it off but
you shouldn't blow it off we are fans of
jordan harbinger's show here at the
daily wire jordan's show which apple
named one of its best of 2018 is aimed
at making you a better informed more
critical thinker so you can get a sense
of how the world actually works and come
to your own conclusions about what's
happening even inside your own brain
each episode is a conversation with a
different fascinating guest and when i
say there's something for everyone here
i mean that i mean he talks to people
like hostage negotiators from the fbi or
kobe bryant or jack schaefer it's just
something different and new pretty much
every time and even if you disagree with
jordan you'll find something that you
find interesting even though i don't
always agree with jordan i'm not sure
jordan always agrees with jordan you'll
find something fascinating and you'll
learn something by listening to his show
we here at daily wire enjoy the show you
will too check out jordanharbinger.com
start for some episode recommendations
or search for the jordan harbinger show
that's h-a-r-b is in boy ian's and nancy
ger on apple podcast spotify or wherever
you listen to podcasts alrighty so
joe biden has a problem with supply
chains right all the prices are going up
people are not going to get what they
need in time for the holidays everything
is taking a really long time to be
delivered at this point and so joe
biden's solution is just yell at the
reporters and the american people
it's it's they who don't understand
don't you know
just kind of keels over here's joe biden
if we were all
going out and having lunch together and
i said
let's ask whoever the whoever's in the
next table no matter how
wh what restaurant we're in have haven't
explained the supply chain to us
you didn't understand what we're talking
about all i can say is what i'm going to
try to do is explain to the american
people as best i can
and by the way you all write for a
living
i haven't seen any one of you explain
supply chain very well
no no i'm not being critical
i'm being deadly earnest when your
editor says explain the supply chain
okay
i'd love to hear joe biden explain the
supply chain
and honestly i'm not sure which end more
hot air comes out of when it comes to
joe biden i really don't know
and he's just
i have love for him really give us a
disquisition on the supply chain joe by
the way the media coverage on the supply
chain hasn't been wrong i've read the
articles on the air from the wall street
journal in detail about the supply chain
from scotland to come i've read details
about the supply chain i'm ready for
national review i've read you from the
new york times joe biden doesn't know
anything about the supply chain because
joe biden doesn't know anything about
anything
and he's continue but you the american
people are ignorant you are ignorant
when you go to the grocery store and
you're paying like
30 more than you were six months ago
that's cause you're stupid if you only
understood you'd know that joe biden is
doing all the right things the magic is
happening you're just too ignorant and
the reason you're too ignorant is not
because joe biden is bad at his job it's
because the media
who pretty much spend every waking
moment trying to clean up joe biden's
mess the one that he made in his bed
every morning the media whose job it is
should be his night nurse along with jen
saki and the white house press office
he's saying they don't do a good enough
job he's the one crapping the bed it's
just everybody else is doing a bad
enough job or noticing that it stinks
and then joe biden was trying to brag
about the economy on friday again all of
this is just you wonder why he's
flailing because he's flailing because
he is who he is and his administration
is very bad at this
america's getting back to work
our economy is starting to work for more
americans
thanks to the economic plan we put
through in congress earlier this year
and a successful vaccine deployment
america continues to add jobs at a
record pace
in its historically
strong recovery unemployment rate has
fallen again today
down to 4.6 percent
this included a substantial drop in
unemployment for hispanics which was
much needed
our economy is on the move okay well it
would be a lot more on the move you get
the hell out of the way
and that means if you would stop at this
vaccine mandate nonsense because a lot
of people are going to drop out of the
workforce because again the vax mandate
is going to force them to either vax or
get fired come january 4th and there are
some testing provisions those could go
away under a permanent osha rule
he said joe biden spent the same day
that he was talking up the economic
response the same day he was talking
about a wonderful job he was doing on
the supply chain he was pushing forward
a vaccine mandate that is in fact not
popular i'm sorry it isn't the polls
show that 50 of americans is the last
poll that i saw i think it was abc news
50 of americans don't like the vax
mandates 47 percent of americans do like
the vax mandates and of people who
really really dislike the vax mandates
it's like 41 really dislike the vax
mandates as opposed to low authorities
who really really like the vast mandates
in other words as as this begins to hit
home and as people realize that they are
not in fact if they are vaccinated at
risk from the unvaccinated
this is particularly true once this
pfizer pill comes out that's supposed to
reduce hospitalization and death after a
covert diagnosis by somewhere up where
of 90 percent
then why exactly would they be listening
to joe biden about the popularity
vaccine mandates
but he has to push it so here he was
pushing it
these requirements have broad public
support
and they work
already we've seen organizations that
have adopted vaccination requirements
increased their vaccination rates
by more than 20 percentage points
often as high as 90 over 90 percent
this is good for the workers
for their colleagues for their loved
ones and for their communities
it's also good for the economy okay i'm
gonna need some evidence on any of this
stuff
why is it why is it good for workers to
be forced to take something that they
don't want to take
why is it why is that good for them it
may be his judgment that is good for
them i may think that they should but it
seems to me that in a free country you
get to make that call particularly if
you are young and healthy
but the idea is that you don't get to
make that call this old daughtering fool
gets to make that call for you okay well
there is a piece of good news here and
that is that the fifth circuit court of
appeals has now stayed the vaccine
mandate in its entirety
according to wibw one day after kansas
joined six other states in a lawsuit in
the sixth circuit court of appeals to
stay the osha covid 19 vaccine mandate
the fifth circuit stayed the biden
administration's move so we here at
daily wire we did file a federal lawsuit
with the sixth circuit court of appeals
so we were waiting on that in the
meantime the fifth circuit court of
appeals issued in order to stay the
entire mandate and the entirety of their
stay was basically this doesn't even
look remotely constitutional
it's like a it's like a page and a half
order
it just says quote because the petitions
give cause to believe there are grave
statutory and constitutional issues with
the mandate the mandate is hereby stayed
pending further action by this court
that's that's literally the whole thing
they don't get into any details they
don't really explain it they're just
like yeah i'm the face of this this
thing is bullcrap and we are not going
to stand for it so no they are not
popular no there is no evidence that
they make a large scale difference and
no they are not constitutional in all
likelihood so joe biden is on the ropes
right
and it gets worse for joe biden
because buildback better is on the ropes
as well remember joe manchin and kirsten
cinema now have no interest in passing
bill back better as it is currently
constituted the democrats keep lying and
saying that they have the support of all
democrats on billback better they do not
have the support of kirsten cinema and
joe manchin both of whom are from either
red or purple states
and what exactly is the incentive
structure for manchin to vote for bill
back better now to give joe biden what
he wants especially when joe biden is
playing all sorts of numeric games with
the bill the bill is not 1.8 1.75
trillion it's not 1.85 trillion it's
more like 4 trillion
because they play all these little games
where they set up a program that expires
in a year knowing that it won't expire
in a year
joe manchin knows that kirsten cinema
knows that and so joe biden his
signature piece of legislation is bill
back better and that is falling apart
nancy pelosi on friday wanted to bring
up bill back better for a vote in the
house
she couldn't get the votes the votes
just didn't exist for it so here is
nancy pelosi pushing bill back better
she was literally getting laughed at in
the room by republicans
if you're talking about how we want to
have immediate and enduring difference
for the workers and families creating
jobs securing middle class tax cuts
lowering cost per families and making
the wealthiest pay their fair share all
the while contributing to reducing the
national debt
making everyone pay their fair share did
i hear a laugh over there did i hear a
lot from those who added two trillion
dollars in tax cuts for the richest
people in america one percent 83 percent
of it going to the top one percent this
is paid for and more than paid so people
were laughing at her because she said it
was going to contribute to lowering the
deficit which 100 it will not do
100 and people are laughing at her at
the room no you can't laugh at me you
guys raise the national debt by cutting
a current taxes
okay the spending never went down that
is true you guys are raising the
national debt by blowing out the
spending to record levels and you don't
even have the votes inside your own
caucus for it we'll get to more of joe
biden trying to strong-arm build back
better into reality in just one second
first if you are a business owner it can
be tough to hire top talent for your
team especially when you're competing
with other businesses to find the right
people so how can you get that hiring
edge that you need zip recruiter will
help you out their invite to apply
feature lets you invite the best
candidates to apply for your open roles
and now you can try it for free at
zippercrew.com dailywire how does invite
to apply work well when you post a job
on zip recruiter you start getting the
most qualified people sent to you very
quickly then you can easily review
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply with one click next
key marketing manager aaron hartgee
loves invites to apply she says quote
they get my job posting in front of the
right people i instantly see great
candidates and i can invite them to
apply to my job in fact according to zip
recruiters internal data on average for
2020 jobs where employers use invite to
apply get two and a half times more
candidates which helps make for a lot
faster hiring process take it from aaron
who says quote you can basically tell
zip recruiter who you need when you need
it and they deliver see it for yourself
just go to this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e to try zip recruiter
for free zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire okay so joe biden
is trying to push buildback better as
well and he's doing so with class
warfare nonsense that's going nowhere so
on friday he said you know the the
wealthy added value to the country but
they didn't build the country noah's
government apparently according to joe
biden who built the country
the the wealthy are are are value-added
to the country but they didn't build a
country
hard-working middle-class folks are the
ones that built this country
they're the ones that built the milk
they're the ones that built the backbone
of the country
and what i decided to do
was i said we have to begin to build the
economy from the bottom up in the middle
out
well folks
that hadn't been the case
i'm so tired about trickle-down economic
theory that i'm trickled out
he has trickled out i mean in a wide
variety of ways things are trickling out
of joe biden it's unfortunate but that
sphincter is just not operating as it
used to you hit a certain age in life
and things begin to fall apart on you
pretty fast by the way when he says
stuff like the wealthy didn't build this
country let's just be clear about
something in the united states the way
that people become wealthy is by
building the country
that is the way that you become wealthy
in the united states you generate
products and services and goods that
other people need
it's not as though there's a class of
people called the wealthy and they build
the country
the notion that hereditary wealth is
what drives the united states is not
true
the vast majority of people who become
wealthy in the united states did not
start off wealthy
i mean every wealthy person that i
personally know did not start off
wealthy virtually all of them that
includes me it includes my business
partners
right my business partners were dirt
poor
so this notion that if you are wealthy
now you didn't help build the country
that was quote unquote the middle class
who built the country there is no group
of people who are called the middle
class you're not middle class your
entire life my parents went from being
low income to middle income to high
income to retiring right this is what
happens over the course of most
americans lives that's what happens in a
free country where there is income
mobility
but joe biden is trying to push the
notion that the federal government has
got to spend ungodly amounts of money
because somehow this is going to spur
growth somehow this is going to do it
and it's failing he just doesn't have
support for any of this he can't get the
progressives together with the moderates
in his own wing he can't do it he's
having a tough time on build back better
and uh and reporters are asking about it
they're saying to joe biden you know
as we'll get to in a second the
republicans are blowing this nearly as
bad as biden is because of course they
are of course they are but our reporters
said divided over the weekend you know
you're not going to have gop votes for
bill back better to get you over the
finish line so what exactly is your plan
here
to get this first agenda item over the
finish line you need republican votes
you're not going to have republican
votes though for your build back better
agenda isn't it doomed i think what's
going to happen is we're going to see
what happens in the senate and whether
or not i need only democratic votes
which is likely which is the likely
outcome and the question is can i get
all of those votes this is a process
and all along you told me i can't do any
of it anyway
yeah yeah he everybody said
he is so obnoxious
between his screaming at people about
how upset he is about trump and his
weird
gazing into camera and leaning forward
all creepy
like he's living in a sewer and waiting
for a small child to come he's going to
attract him with a balloon
i don't know like
i don't know what's going on with joe
biden but that guy is there's a reason
why he's in the low 40s in terms of his
approval rating kevin mccarthy the house
minority leader he says pretty obvious
at this point that every element of joe
biden's agenda is a failure this is
correct of course
every element of his philosophy and
policy has been a failure and it's not
my opinion it's the opinion of the
millions of people who just voted last
tuesday to send him a very clear message
but nancy pelosi and president biden are
tied together because two times he's
come down to
these chambers and asked people to vote
for those failed policies
okay and and two times he failed and
then on friday they failed again with
regard to build back better because joe
manchin and kirsten cinema are not on
board with this and joe biden continues
to fail right and it's going to continue
to drive failure across the board in
2022 which democrats know in which they
are extremely scared of there's an
article in the washington post today
about joe biden's failures in rural
areas which are getting worse politico
similar article there's an article in
the new york times today called
democrats thought they bottomed out in
rural white america it was not the
bottom
quote the increasingly liberal politics
of virginia had been a sore spot for
residents of this conservative town of
499 people nestled in the allegheny
mountains but this past week as
republicans stormed to marquis victories
powered in part by turnout in rural
areas like bath county local voters
cheered
we got our virginia backs at elaine f a
61 year old resident we haven't had a
win in a long time neff said she cried
from a mix of happiness and relief after
the election she doesn't want to take
the coveted vaccine she believes glenn
youngkin will relax state mandates
outside a nearby grocery store charles
hamilton taunted the democrats he said
we're a county of old country folk who
want to do what they want they found out
the hard way in the jigsaw puzzle that
is electoral politics democrats have
often focused their energy on swinging
suburbs and voter-rich cities content to
mostly ignore many white rural
communities that lean conservative the
belief was in part that the party had
already bottomed out there especially
during the trump era virginia however is
proved it can get worse in 2008 there
were only small four small virginia
counties where republicans won 70 or
more of the vote in that year's
presidential race nowhere was the party
above 75
this year young kin was above 70
in 45 counties 45 says four in 2008.
this year young kid was above 70
in 45 counties and above 80 in 15 of
them
steve bullock former democratic governor
of montana said look at some of these
rural counties in virginia as a wake-up
call folks don't feel like we're
offering them anything or hearing or
listening to them
this is of course correct the democrats
have abandoned the rural areas they've
abandoned the non-college educated white
vote and the american people are
fighting back against that because
there's still a huge number of americans
who are white and non-college educated
and those people are voting increasingly
for the republicans but it's not just
that the suburbs turned against terry
mcauliffe in virginia in new jersey it
was not about
critical race theory in virgin in new
jersey it was just about complete
disapproval for joe biden's agenda
and the more democrats pursue woke
nonsense the worse it's going to get for
them
it's not going to pay off for them so
joe biden is in serious trouble right
joe biden is flailing joe biden is
falling apart
well there's only one thing joe biden
can count on and that is for the
republicans to be just as stupid as he
is unfortunately he found some we'll get
to that in just one second first let us
talk about how you keep your home safe
and secure this holiday season deck the
halls walls windows and doors with best
deals of the year on the award-winning
ring alarm i'm sure we all know about
the ring video doorbell by now but did
you know that ring makes an
award-winning alarm as well ring alarm
is a powerful affordable home security
system you can easily install yourself
whether you're running across town or
across the country this busy season you
and your loved ones can rest easy
knowing your home is protected and it's
more than just security ring alarm
protects your home from flood freeze and
fire as well plus it's way cheaper than
those other companies for what they
charge for one month you get an entire
year of ring alarm with professional
monitoring right now for the best deals
of the year on ring alarm go to ring.com
forward slash ben this holiday season
make sure that you deck those halls
walls windows and doors with the best
deals of the year on ring alarm again i
rely on ring alarm every time i go out
of town i want to keep track of what's
going on on my property i count on ring
alarm to make that happen
not just that even when i'm home i've
got to keep track of my kids because
they're totally wild and one will
disappear and i'm like uh oh where'd the
baby go pop up that ring app now i know
go to ring.com to get a great deal on a
ring alarm security kit today that is
ring dot com forward slash pentagon ring
dot com forward slash ben okay so with
joe biden flailing you would imagine
that republicans would just let him
flail would you not that of course would
be the smart move
however you can always count on
republicans to be as stupid as humanly
possible at least a small percentage of
them
because
late on friday the house of
representatives passed a roughly 1
trillion publix works bill sending to
president biden's desk a generational
investment in roads bridges and rail
that had languished for several months
as democrats feuded over the terms of
its approval now you'll remember that
this thing has already passed the senate
and that mitt romney had voted for it
and that susan collins had voted for it
and rob portman and ohio had voted for
it and then joe biden didn't want the
house to only vote on it right joe biden
wanted to tie that together with bill
back better the idea being that if
mansion and cinema wanted their
bipartisan bipartisan infrastructure
plan passed they would also have to vote
in favor of build back better then it
turned out that mansion and cinema
weren't going to budge and then biden
was stuck in a pickle because the
progressives said we will not vote for
bipartisan infrastructure unless we get
a vote for manchin and cinema and build
back better right camilla jayapal had
led that way as well
well late last week carmilla triapult
basically caved on it
pramila jayapal was like okay fine you
know what we know that we're not going
to be able to hold up the bipartisan
infrastructure plan to get mansion in
cinema cave so we do want that
bipartisan infrastructure plan passed we
will vote in favor of it with like a
basic proviso that maybe will get a vote
on billback better sometime down the
road
and so on friday a statement came out
from the moderate wing of the democratic
party saying they will commit to voting
for the build back better act in its
current form other than technical
changes they still want the cost from
the cbo by the week of november 15th
they say they will resolve any
discrepancies that come up in the
interim to get it passed but that
doesn't matter because again mansion and
cinema are the ones who actually matter
in this particular conversation but then
pramila jayapal put out a statement
saying quote tonight members of the
progressive caucus and our colleagues in
the democratic caucus reached an
agreement to advance both pieces of
president biden's legislative agenda our
colleagues have committed to voting for
the transformative buildback better act
as currently written no later than the
week of november 15th all of our
colleagues have also committed to voting
tonight on the rule to move the build
back better act forward to codify this
promise the president has affirmed these
members gave him the same commitment
okay but there was one problem left
because he had the progressives and the
moderates saying we'll vote for some
rule to ex to push forward bill back
better even though we know it's probably
going to die a horrible painful death in
the senate
and we'll vote in favor of bipartisan
infrastructure there's one problem you
still had six outstanding democrats
namely the squad and their adjunct
members who are voting against
bipartisan infrastructure democrats
could only afford to lose three votes
and still pass bipartisan infrastructure
in the house
right so they've lost six which means
they didn't have the votes for either
build back better or for the bipartisan
infrastructure act because they lacked
the votes for bipartisan infrastructure
in the house and they didn't have the
votes for bill back better in the senate
so this is the point where if you're
republican you stand there and you let
them flail
you just let them flail right because
why would you hand them a win
well the answer is because republicans
at least 13 of them are just complete
morons
and or they are so eager to slap their
own party in the face that they voted
against the rest of their republican
colleagues in order to vote for this
infrastructure plan which again is a
giant boondoggle it is 1.2 trillion of
spending that are unnecessary the vast
majority of infrastructure spending that
needs to be done is supposed to be done
at the state level
the notion that america's infrastructure
is completely failing all of our bridges
and roads are falling apart it's not
true
and by most non-partisan studies the
united states infrastructure is in the
main okay
and if you want to upgrade it that is
something that can be done at the state
level there's no reason why florida
should be paying for new york's
infrastructure problems
okay but nonetheless you had 13
republicans who then voted in favor of
the bipartisan infrastructure bill and
handed flailing joe biden a falling
apart show biden a win
which is just garbage it's just garbage
it's senator bill hagerty of tennessee
he says yeah there's no question the
republicans bailed nancy pelosi out
right here
how do you feel as a republican about
those 13 who voted for this
well neil you recall that i fought this
very hard in the senate um it was very
surprising to me to see 13 republicans
basically bail nancy pelosi out she did
not have the votes within her own party
to do this we had 13 republicans that
decided to step up and help her in this
way i think what they did was put
themselves on a path to early retirement
and that is correct
every person on the republican side of
the aisle who voted in favor of the
infrastructure plan to get primary to
every single one of these people
and they include some moderates you know
people like jeff fandrew who used to be
a democrat
by the way there how many members of how
many republican members from new york
alone voted for this thing one two
let's see one two three
four
there are four from new york who voted
for this plus another two from new
jersey
so basically it's new york and new
jersey that voted in favor of this thing
right new york and new jersey voted in
favor of this thing and everybody else
is like nope we're not doing it
he had a couple of others he had done
young from alaska you had fred upton
from michigan but every single member
who voted for this thing on the right
side of the aisle should be primary you
don't get to vote for joe biden's
signature pieces of legislation at a
time when we've already blown out the
spending and when inflation is setting
in
and when we already have a debt to gdp
ratio higher than at any time since
world war ii
and then get to survive a primary
challenge that is not something that
should happen inside the republican
party it's a disgrace
according to the wall street journal a
major piece of mr biden's economic
agenda and his vision for making the u.s
more competitive internationally its
passage in the house hands him a
bipartisan achievement that presidents
of both parties have tried and failed to
achieve for years again remember he had
to do this with republican votes he
could not accomplish it with just
democratic votes so this is republican's
fault
i don't know what house speaker mccarthy
had to do to make sure that those 13
republicans didn't go along with joe
biden here or if there's anything he
could have done but bottom line is if
you cannot whip your party hard enough
to ensure that they don't vote for the
other guy on a bill that has no interior
support inside the republican party i
don't know what you are doing
his sagging poll numbers and democrats
recent loss in the gubernatorial race in
virginia had pushed democrats to muscle
the legislation through the finish line
this week but the effort was circuitous
and tortured for house democrats whose
paper thin majority repeatedly
complicated leadership's plan for the
legislation democrats had started friday
planning to approve the infrastructure
bill after passing the rest of the
party's priorities in a separate roughly
2 trillion education healthcare and
climate package
progressive democrats demanded the
social spending legislation first
receive a vote in the house hoping to
ensure that centrist would support it
that design then fell apart because
centrist democrats said they needed more
time to analyze the cost of the social
spending bill so then pelosi just
brought up the infrastructure bill and
she didn't have the votes she brought up
for a vote and she didn't have the votes
these 13 republicans bailed out nancy
pelosi
they bailed him they bailed her out
it's unbelievable
and what exactly is the rationale for
this
seriously where is the deep-seated
republican need to pass this thing
it's just it's just garbage and
stupidity and a lot of it is spiked by
some of these members you'll notice a
lot of names that voted for trump's
impeachment who are on that same list
right there i don't think that that's a
coincidence
what a disaster area this of course
allowed joe biden to go out there and
mock trump and try to take a triumphant
lap now the the triumph is not going to
last for very long
it really is not because the truth is
the infrastructure bill is going to help
virtually no one and no one thinks it's
going to help them so it's just going to
look like a big bag of spending it's
going to allow him to say that he did an
uh bipartisan thing which is the only
bipartisan thing that has happened
throughout his entire administration
again i thought this is a bad move from
the time that republicans agreed to it
and i think that in the senate the math
for mitt romney and susan collins and
company was probably that if they got
mansion and cinema on board with
bipartisan infrastructure that this
would also get them to stand up against
buildback better so it's one or the
other in the senate but in the house it
wasn't in the house the house
republicans could just say no and that
would have been the end of it then it
would have been toast it would have been
done
instead they handed biden to victory and
he got out he got to go out there and uh
and triumphally make his uh appeal to
the american people
infrastructure week
i'm so happy to say that
he's making fun of trump of course
because every week in trump's
administration was infrastructure week
and infrastructure never really got done
and of course he had to bring it's
hilarious how they've been stashing
kamala harris away and only when they do
something that is camera friendly do
they sort of trot her out and then they
just shove her right back wherever she
came from it's okay you need to go back
into that closet there and stay there
kamala until next time when we try you
out and pretend that you had something
to do with with any of this according to
cnn both biden and his cabinet officials
are now going to go on an infrastructure
tour which is what americans are up for
i mean there's nothing that sounds like
as much fun as an infrastructure tour
and it sounds like you know just a great
band or something it's gonna be awesome
today the president touted the bill at
the white house and
cnn has now learned that biden and his
top cabinet officials plan to hit the
road and tour the country in the coming
weeks to promote the benefits of this
bill oh how exciting they're going to
run around the country talking about how
much of your money they're now spending
by the way what exactly is in the bill
it includes 110 billion in funding for
roads bridges and major projects as well
as 39 billion to modernize and make
public transit more accessible to the
disabled and the elderly most of that is
going to go to new york and a huge chunk
of that is going to go to new york city
so i'm glad that you get to pay for new
york subway system that's exciting stuff
also you will notice that the price tag
on this bipartisan infrastructure bill
is something like 1.2 trillion dollars
and yet the bill is 110 billion for
roads bridges and other major projects
when most people think of infrastructure
that is what they think of right
that is not where most of the bill's
money goes the deal includes a 66
billion investment in rail maintenance
most of which will go to amtrak
amtrak so joe biden finally got to bail
out his favorite train because that dude
loves amtrak and tells all sorts of lies
about all the people he's met on amtrak
and
he he treats his travel on amtrak as
some sort of actual presidential
credential
the legislation will provide 11 billion
dollars in funding for highway and
pedestrian safety programs and what that
means what is a pedestrian safety
program telling people not to walk on
freeways or what a total of 7.5 billion
will go to implementing a network of
electric vehicle chargers because again
it is not as though private companies
have an incentive to ensure that there
are evs
charging at their stations and we
actually need to have the state do it
because if the state doesn't do it then
probably nobody will build it except for
how there are ev chargers at pretty much
every gas station now but aside from
that another 7.5 billion will be used
for zero emission or low emission buses
and ferries ports and airports will be
boosted with 42 billion dollars in new
spending
also they're going to put 65 billion
dollars toward broadband infrastructure
and development
it'll include 73 billion to update and
expand the power grid
how exactly are they going to pay for
all of this well
they're going to have 200 billion
dollars in repurposed funds originally
intended for coronavirus relief but left
unused
so they're just taking all the money
they're supposed to spend for covert
relief and they're going to dump it on
this
about 50 billion will come from delaying
a trump era rule on medicare rebates
50 billion from certain states returning
unused unemployment insurance
supplemental funds
also senators say they expect 30 billion
to be generated from applying
information reporting requirements for
cryptos they're going to tax crypto
essentially nearly 60 billion will come
from the economic growth spurred by the
spending yeah sure
yeah i'm sure because so much economic
growth is going to get spurred by
wasting this amount of money
the non-partisan scorekeeper found the
infrastructure bill would widen the
federal budget deficit by about 256
billion dollars over 10 years so no it's
not going to be covered
how about human infrastructure
well they're still going to be pushing
that in buildback better so very
exciting stuff
okay so again republicans hand biden an
imagistic victory here for no apparent
reason
and uh there should be blowback on all
13 members of the house who decided to
vote in favor of the again a giant
spending monstrosity that was
unnecessary in the first place and that
allows joe biden a victory lap at a time
when his presidency is in a state of
complete collapse political malpractice
in the extreme
okay meanwhile things continue to get
bizarre and stupid in blue states we'll
get to california's new take on woke
math in just one second first let's talk
about a simple fact you're paying too
much for gas right now right we're all
paying too much for gas right now if
you're in a blue state you're definitely
paying too much for gas right now this
is why you need get upside my listeners
are making up to 25 cents for every
gallon of gas every time they fill up
just download the free get upside app in
the app store or google play right now
and you can use promo code shapiro and
get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on your
first fill up that's up to 50 cents cash
back pretty solid deal right there don't
pay full price of the pump anymore get
cash back using get upside just download
the app for free use promo code shapiro
to get up to 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your very first tank of gas
some people who drive a lot are making
as much as two to three hundred bucks a
month in cash back there is no cash the
cash back gets added directly to your
account you can cash out anytime your
bank account paypal or an e-gift card
for amazon and other brands just
download the free get upside app use
promo code shapiro to get up to 50 cents
per gallon cash back on your very first
tank of gas that is code shapiro go
check them out right now and go to the
get upside app use promo code shapiro
get up to 50 cents per gallon cash back
on your very first tank of gas everybody
needs to save money on that gas right
now get upside helps you do it go
download the app use promo code at
shapiro for the special deal alrighty
we'll get some more in just one second
first last week as you know dailywire
announced we have filed a lawsuit
against the federal government it's an
unprecedented move staring down the face
of an increasingly authoritarian
president leaves us with no other option
the daily wires lawsuit was filed by the
dylan law group inc and alliance
defending freedom in the u.s circuit
court of appeals for the sixth circuit
the lawsuit alleges that the biden
administration lacks constitutional and
statutory authority to issue the
employer mandate and that the mandate
failed to meet the requirements for
issuing a rule taking effect immediately
without the normal process of
considering public comment right which
is exactly right they're saying it's
emergency temporary standard except for
biden announced in two months in advance
and then it doesn't take effect for two
months which is not the emergency
temporary standard so they've avoided
comments and also it's not an emergency
the mandate's unconstitutional they're
not going to stand for it our employees
deserve to keep their medical history
private have autonomy over their own
bodies and honor any of their religious
beliefs we stand with their rights we do
it the rights of every single american
the body administration has warned that
any companies that do not comply with
this federal overreach could be fined as
much as 136 thousand dollars per
violation so we need your help if you're
not a member yet please consider joining
us today go to dailywire.com subscribe
enter code do not comply check out
you'll receive 25 off your membership
fight the unconstitutional mandate with
us we appreciate your help we will not
comply as always we have even more
exciting news here at the daily wire we
are now launching daily wire now which
means you will be able to stream all
your favorite daily wear shows on vizio
smartcast tune in to watch candace
discuss current events with guests
ranging from donald trump to dana white
or catch one of your favorite hoes i
know listen we're all talking about me
there's always something interesting to
stream tune in to watch daily wire now
exclusively on vizio watch free plus
streaming app on channel 162 to access
the content you love 24 hours a day
seven days a week only on vizio
smartcast you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
well meanwhile again republicans saving
democrats from themselves it's the
stupidest thing they can do because the
fact is that on the cultural issues
republicans are winning and they're
winning big this is why i actually think
that even though a bunch of foolish and
backward republicans voted in favor of
the infrastructure bill i think it's
going to have no long-term effects i
don't think the democrats can save
themselves i think the democrats are too
tied in to an ideology that is
completely at odds with how americans
think i'm just going to give you an
example of somebody who's very tied in
to this ideology that of course is joy
reid who represents the hard left wing
of the democratic party so over the
weekend joy reid decided to rip on
winsome sears again and it's it's insane
what people on the left think they can
get away with with regards to speaking
about rays it really is quite disgusting
and now this ar-15 wheeled in lg will be
their new get out of racism free card
while republicans nationwide make ban
all history that shows any white person
doing anything wrong to black people
ever
their 2022 mantra
it's just incredible so according to joy
reid winston sears the new lieutenant
governor elect of virginia is actually a
just get out of racism free card for
republicans
pretty impressive stuff there and
unfortunately this is how democrats
think and most americans are not into it
because it has real effect on how people
live so the best example of this comes
from my former state i'm so glad i left
of california according to the new york
times california tries to close the gap
in math but sets off a backlash
it's by j.c thornton it's an
unbelievable article quote if everything
had gone according to plan california
would have approved new guidelines this
month for math education in public
schools but ever since a draft was
opened for public comment in february
the recommendations have set off a
fierce debate over not only how to teach
math but also how to solve a problem
more intractable than firmit's last
theorem closing the racial and
socioeconomic disparities in achievement
that persist at every level of math
education
now the reality is that if you want to
look at the disparities that exist at
every level of math education you might
have to start with family structure you
might have to start with the number of
hours of homework that people are doing
you might have to start with the
educational values of particular
communities which differ widely
and this is not a racial thing they're
appalachian white communities where
education is not valued and so people
underperform in schools
and there are asian communities where
education is highly valued and so people
over-perform in schools
but according to california
the mere fact of disparity means that
they seriously considered shifting how
they're going to teach math now math is
again the it is the key
component
is the key example rather of meritocracy
at work now honestly the term
meritocracy i think has been overused
and the reason i think that the term
meritocracy has been overused is because
when we say that meritocracy rewards
merit people tend to think of that as
moral merit in some cases that's true
right stick-to-itiveness grit working
hard these are in fact merits that are
rewarded by a free market system
but testing and and objective standards
very often they're not actually
measuring quote-unquote moral merit
they're measuring something else right
they might be measuring iq it might be
measuring how smart you are and your
skill set and what you've learned and
all of that okay so when we say
meritocracy really what people should be
saying is something like a skillsocracy
right and the good news about
skillsocracies right about places where
skills are rewarded is when people are
rewarded for high levels of skill that
has excellent externalities
if you construct a system where people's
skills are rewarded rather than say
their color or rather their than their
ethnicity or their age or their religion
what this means is that the activities
of the people who are skilled
generally tend to help other people if
you reward skill sets then those skill
sets and and those skill sets are
awarded because the person with the
skills can use those skill sets in order
to do something for another person right
this is how free market trades work i
have an excellent skill set i use my
skills to produce a product or good or
service for you and then you use your
skill set to in turn enrich me
this is how free market trades work and
consensual exchanges work a skills
accuracy is really good because it
rewards people who have high levels of
skill which means that they are
bettering the lives of all the people
who they provide services goods and
products too
it's the best form of distributing an
elevated standard of living to more and
more people and most innovation happens
at the top levels of the skillsocracy
and people have higher skill levels
whether it's just
purely in in terms of innovation or
whether it's in terms of being really
good at their own jobs that bleeds that
does bleed to everybody else because it
raises the level of the products and
services people are privy to so you want
a skillsocracy okay the alternatives are
completely randomized
insanities like ethnocracies where you
get rewarded based on your skin color or
victimocracy where you get rewarded or
punished based on your group's history
of being a victim or being an oppressor
and that has no good externalities it
doesn't help anybody it makes things
significantly worse because anything
that is not a skillsocracy punishes
skill it makes skill a secondary factor
this is what california is seeking to do
so the california guidelines could
overhaul the way many school districts
approach math instruction the draft
rejected the idea of naturally gifted
children
recommended against shifting certain
students into accelerated courses in
middle school and tried to promote
high-level math courses that could serve
as alternatives to calculus like data
science or statistics okay so first of
all if you reject the idea of naturally
gifted children it's because you're an
idiot
some kids are gifted period end of story
some kids have higher iqs than others
and shock of shocks it turns out that
there is a heavy heavy genetic component
to that that if both parents are
neuroscientists there's a good shot that
their kid is going to have a higher iq
than somebody both of whose parents are
on welfare
okay that is just
i'm not saying that's inevitably true
there are many smart people who are on
welfare i'm sure they're not all that
many stupid neuroscientists but they're
i'm sure smart people on welfare
but
if you have to take the average person
and all you know about them is child of
two neuroscientists versus child of two
people on welfare in a free american
society
and all you have to go on is that whose
kid do you think is gonna have the
higher iq okay so to pretend that that
doesn't exist in real life is stupid
it's just dumb it's like saying that two
tall parents are not likely to have a
height-gifted child
where i mean how could we possibly say
that some people are more height-gifted
than others to pretend that intelligence
isn't inborn at all and we are all sort
of tabula rasa is silly it's just not
true by any available metric okay but
this is what california wanted to teach
they recommended against shifting
students into accelerated courses and
because they want to punish skill sets
they want to defeat the skillsocracy the
last thing you want to do is reward
people who are gifted who by the way
should use their gift on behalf of
society in a free market society free
markets allow people to distribute the
uses of their gifts widely this is the
magic of free markets everybody on the
left thinks that free markets make you
more selfish
that is untrue free markets mean that
unless i give you something that you
want i starve that's what a free market
does
socialism makes you more selfish because
it assumes that i can sit here on my ass
all day and you have to give me
something for my trouble
so this is what california is pushing
now
the battle over math comes at a time
when education policy on issues
including masks testing and teaching
about racism has become entangled in
bitter partisan debate the republican
candidate for governor in virginia glen
youngkin seized on those issues to help
propel him to victory on tuesday now
republicans are discussing how these
education issues can help them in a
midterm election next year even in
heavily democratic california the draft
guidelines encountered scathing
criticism with charges that the
framework would inject woke politics
into a subject that is supposed to be
practical and precise
joe buller professor of education at
stanford said quote people will really
go to battle for maths to stay the same
even parents who hated maths in schools
will argue to keep it the same for their
kids
the battle over math pedagogy is a tale
as old as multiplication tables an idea
called new math had its heyday in the
1960s about a decade ago many debates
over the national common core standards
broke out as well today battles over the
california guidelines are circling
around a fundamental question what or
whom is math4 this is the stupidest
question i've ever heard the answer is
math is for everyone because it helps
everyone and if you're not good at math
tough math still exists
testing results show regularly that math
students in the united states are
lagging behind those in other
industrialized nations within the
country there's a persistent racial gap
in achievement according to data from
the civil rights office of the education
department black students represented
about 16 percent of high school students
but eight percent of those enrolled in
calculus during the 2015-2016 school
years white and asian students were
overrepresented in high-level courses
critics of the draft said the authors
would punish high achievers by limiting
options for gifted programs
william williamson evers senior fellow
at the independent institute was one of
the authors of the letter he said that's
not right said math is math two plus two
equals four
and that of course is exactly right
but the this is not what california is
moving toward california is is moving
toward the idea that everyone should be
given an equal result even if they are
not equally good at math
the the the detracting movement is an
attempt to destroy the skills accuracy
in favor of some other
moral component that is brought by the
left that has no basis in reality
so if california and the rest of the
left wishes to pursue this they are
going to reap the world one and i'm not
sure that they can pull out of this
tailspin so yeah it's bad that
republicans voted for the infrastructure
plan every republican who did should be
punished for it
but in the end the democrats have
embraced a suicidal strategy with regard
to the american people who will not
accept the substitution of any metric
other than a skillsocracy
because if they do they've substituted
bigotry for freedom alrighty we'll be
back here later today with an additional
hour of content in the meantime go check
out our newest podcast morning wire
today's episode is available right now
on apple spotify or wherever you listen
to podcasts make sure to tune in i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire
on today's episode a federal court halts
biden's employer vaccine mandate the
infrastructure bill finally passes and a
closer look at the electoral red wave
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire